[Musica]
[Applauso]
palombi
[Musica]
no
taiwan
[Musica]
cala
era secca
vai
[Musica]
l'hotel
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ogni giorno ci spera
quel bambino devi votare per non
affogare
[Musica]
sì
ma dove è tornato
giovedì
se la grecia
danneggiamento si lavora
howard
wilde
personaggio quei tour 12 paure quanto
male possono fare lui si sente uguale ma
la società lo vuole emarginare a parlare
di questa situazione siamo stanchi non
lo vedi che prova a tutti quanti non
importa niente fatti con la convinzione
che resterà per sempre non esiste un
vincitore non per le recenti lotta
incessantemente che non sopporto più la
falsità di questa società che non
accetta la diversità è per questo che a
disagio ed ha paura come chi è solo e
combatte stessa la propria armatura se
qualcuno conoscessero in profondità e
sembra possa immaginare qual è la storia
che cos'è la sensibilità
[Musica]
sì
questa volta non si pone come una
campagna sono cresciuto in un quartiere
dove stanno le cose negli occhi e non il
tuo colore o se stesso boni piove anche
se fuori c'è il sole
cerco la libertà dentro per azione
bortolami agenti come status symbol che
non ti soddisfa
[Musica]
quando non ti aspetti
aperto tokyo
[Musica]
buona
mai
[Musica]
sa perché c'è in città e scurati di
abbordaggio da gesto è stato tessera
[Musica]
forse già ben nota ha prodotto
gli occhi
al centro a testa fra miu festa plateau
è svegliati 8 ci spera
chi già tantucci mio prof non lo so se
c'è sempre
[Musica]
special teams
si no
[Musica]
ci spero
chissà
[Musica]
prenderà
sì
[Musica]
peccato
in più
[Musica]
ora la piccola orchestra di tor
pignattara
[Applauso]